[Music]
[Applause]
and uh
she joins us now you're getting spoiled
with your kansas city chiefs there
melissa
i gotta tell you it's a great feeling
it's
something i've never felt before and
indeed look at this
setup here now describe it for the
audience that's only listening on radio
those are watching on peacock they can
see
is this your studio yes this is our
streaming studio when uh the world went
upside down
yeah last year uh and i
realized that i wouldn't be able to have
uh live performances for quite a while
my wife and i came back into our garage
and we transformed it into a
streaming studio where we stream
etheridge tv five days a week
you got a couple of cameras working
there this isn't just
i mean this is some serious cameras and
you do i think no no no i
i have i lead the league in uh in
cameras you have more guitars than i
have but i think i have about
14 cameras in here everything is on
everything's on tv okay so
you got posters back there you got the
lights i went to my warehouse
pulled some stuff out it looks great the
coolest piece of memorabilia you have in
there is what
well probably i've pulled it up here
probably this uh
kansas city chiefs helmet 2000 um
chiefs autographed uh helmet i've got
derek thomas on
what about music um what's that what
about music your favorite piece of me
i i always love the one where your
guitar
is uh over your back oh yeah my
shirtless yeah that's probably
it's my homage to uh bruce guitar slung
over my back
poster yeah that's probably it although
bruce didn't have his shirt off when he
did it
nope that's where i went wait a minute
i'm gonna actually take my shirt off
i have to go one step further what if
tom brady said you know what
gisele and i are we're celebrating our
20th anniversary
melissa would you play at our
anniversary would you
indulge you know that uh wish the
you know because you probably might be
anti-brady being a chiefs fan
well you know it's funny it the huh
i'm able to to have the spirit of a
a sports fan and and you know
say darn that brady how many times has
he kept us from the playoffs how many
times is he you know
and and everything yet i am a person and
i have
uh great respect for a great athlete so
you know i respect the man okay i don't
know if i'd uh
go to his party but i respect the man
but but if mahomes said that
oh hey would you play at my wedding oh
i'm there
i'm there i'm there i i'll bring uh i'll
i'll play all kinds of wedding
songs i can play wedding receptions
absolutely okay so
uh we asked i don't know if we formally
ask you to come up with a new song but
i'm i'm hopeful you do have a new song
for us
well i happen to be standing here with
my guitar okay
and you know it's funny because um i
actually hope every year that i get to
to bring a song to you because it means
that my my chiefs have done very well
and um you know it's funny because i i
i sat down to uh you know just
whip something up because it's always
fun and and um especially about football
and football songs can be strange
but um i um i
actually looked at this whole year and
and thought this whole year was strange
so i wanted to uh
kind of put my thoughts and everything
together and it's actually
it's actually um a song thanking
football
it's called football thank you okay all
right here is ready for it melissa
etheridge the
grammy academy award winner singer
songwriter
uh and die hard chiefs fan
2020 was hard 2020 was strange
well the chiefs were the champs and then
everything changed
[Music]
well my heart grew heavy days were
fearful
and dark would football even happen
the future was stark but the men and
women of the nfl
how they found a way the stands would be
empty
but still they would play and i'd like
to thank
the nfl especially my chiefs
they gave me something to smile about
yeah you saved my sanity
well i know it's just a game but it
really pulled me through
so i just wanna thank you
football thank you
well they played on through december
each team that gave the best
the jets and the jags kind of came up
short in it
see east was just a mess you know the
actress had the mvp
and the browns surprised us all the
bills almost
almost went all the way man that's good
football
i'd like to thank the nfl especially my
chiefs yeah you gave me something to
smile about
you saved my sanity well i know
it's just a game but it really pulled me
through
so i just wanna thank you now football
thank you oh
now brady has a buccaneer well he
deserves all my respect
he brought them to the super bowl yeah
he's a goat
and yet
well i'll take my defense any day
with tyron chris and spags my chiefs
have proved it all year long
that they can run it back with andy's
plays and
kelsey saves when tyrek leaves them
scorched
in the end when brady meets my homes
well
it's time to pass the torch
[Music]
i'd like to thank the nfl especially
my team you gave me something to smile
about
yeah you saved my sanity i
know it's just a game but it really
pulled me through
so i just wanna thank you
football thank you
[Applause]
[Music]
oh you're adorable thank you it's time
to pass the torch that's
great i i love that and the nfc east
line was great too
what is your go-to springsteen song
oh that's probably jungle land or
anything off born to run
have you played that during your shows
you know i did
a um i did a springsteen cover day on
tuesday i do covers
yeah and uh today is southern rock
coverage just letting you know
but um i have done i don't think i did i
don't think i did jungle man
no i haven't actually sang it it's it's
like a it's like a mini rock opera you
know
but do you know bruce i do know bruce he
he um in 1994 he came and sang on my
mtv unplugged we sang thunder road
together is like a highlight of my life
how intimidating is that you know he's
not
he is just as
personable and just a new jersey guy
he's
really really a very nice guy and
just uh he i just love him very much but
i would think
growing up would be a great song for you
my favor i love growing up i love she's
the one
and yeah but they're i mean there's so
many songs
to love about bruce but uh and
not that i could cover any of those but
i i just those are always songs that
resonated with me for some reason
they they make their our history of rock
you know that's it's a big part of
the american life i think but have you
ever run into that
rock star that they acted like a rock
star and it it wasn't a good
good funny i ran into a few of them in
the 80s and 90s
and i don't know where they are now
[Laughter]
um it's great to talk to you i know it's
uh certainly been
a difficult year for you in a variety of
ways and i i hope that uh
etheridge tv the etheridge foundation
tell us more about what you're doing
with your tv show
well on um if you go to etheridgetv.com
you you can buy a ticket to each
separate show
or you can get a monthly subscription
for 50 bucks
and uh what you get is five shows a week
you get tuesday cover songs wednesday i
do a chat so
show with my wife where we talk about
the world and and
bring some laughter into into everything
thursday is called
mama's choice which is deep cuts of uh
um
album tracks and and things that uh
rarely
heard and uh friday is uh we actually go
i
i i've got some like old bootlegs that i
um
show everybody and we talk it's called
the friday night time machine
and then saturday is like a full-on
concert where i i do the hits and
we just play and it keeps me sane by you
know being able to make music and it
pays the bills
and what are you going to be doing on
super bowl sunday
i will be sitting in my chair with a
vat of guacamole and
i will be nervously eating and cheering
on
oh god i just i love wearing the super
bowl again it's really exciting doesn't
that sound like a country song
sitting in my chair with a vat of
guacamole
indeed yeah maybe george strait could do
something like that
i absol absolutely could find something
aren't there certain
there's certain artists though melissa
that it feels like they could like
didn't the beatles prove
you could sing about anything like an
octopuses
garden tax man like just so many crazy
things
they prove that it doesn't matter what
the lyrics are
they can they could sell it if you feel
it i am the walrus cookie
i know okay
ethridgetv.com and uh
thank you again melissa it's great to
see you and good luck to your chiefs
coming up this weekend
and if you want to maybe pre-record a
chief's song
i don't know next week next month or
something like that for the following
super bowl
oh come on like you could be that you
got to be in the moment
oh you got to know what's happening all
right all right i just thought maybe you
wanted to pre-record something take a
little pressure off you there but
maybe it would be called dynasty oh whoa
whoa okay i like it i like it
uh good luck this weekend and thank you
again oh thank you so much dan
much love to all your folks there that's
melissa etheridge singer songwriter and
it's uh ethridgetv.com